avec la pilule du professeur shadow kyo
le ministre de la population a pondu des
shadoks en pièces détachées shadow qu à
une idée pour les rafistoler c'est
excessivement simple suivez mon
raisonnement carton de la cellule sortie
de cette machine et par le truchement de
notre dévoué ministre j'obtiens des
shadoks en pièces détachées par
conséquent ans réagissent non les
mauvais shadoks côté pilule et en
actionnant à l'envers il doit sortir de
notre processus et j'adore couple on va
essayer et alors que son fils de l'autre
côté du mur seules sorties
devinez quoi pum pilule mais ne nous
affolons pas ne nous affolons pas là
nous avons plusieurs solutions première
solution nous ré administrons la pilule
aux ministres nous injectons là et nous
obtenons voyons voyons un oeuf et
ministre et dont le à une autre pilule
mauvaise solution
deuxième solution injectons l'oeuf par
là les jeannot comba orso par là nous
avons une pilule est un ministre en a
déjà un très mauvaise solution
troisième solution la bonne suivez moi
bien nous coupons la paire et le morceau
nous la mettons dans les autres là les
impopulaires
nous invitons nous agitons et nous avons
encore une pilule et et c'est tout eh
bien c'est raté
et non ce n'était pas tout monsieur le
professeur et non ce n'était pas tout
car voilà que la machine
j'émettais a marché voilà qui sait des
pâtes et qu'elle courait après les
pièces détachées et qu'elle les avaler
voilà quelle grosse fait qu'elles
grossissent est qu elle grossissait ont
un énorme tas d'os comptait un shadow
contraire infernal déchaîné famille qui
tout à l'heure va les manger
la dernière heure des châles
occassionnés ils vont mourir à cette
fois oui c'est bien lapin et tout ça à
cause du professeur mais il n'ya une
quatrième solution lab bon votre main la
pilule professeur la pilule dite
un shadok la chine avait englouti sa
pilule comme c'était justement une
pilule a coupé les shadows qu'on morceau
jadot qui s'écoule à un énorme tas de
détritus
c'était fini et il peut encore sauver
cette fois là il s'en passait quand même
de drôles de choses sur la lune
[Musique]